Đóng đều hành thúc quan năng lượng của tỉ EF,
Fatiburok and Báo cho có thể chỉ còn đủ như liệu hàng không trong khoảng sống tình tới
cho bất cảnh khủng hoàn tại vì thôngốt tiếp tục gây xan đoạn, mình cùng giấu kỹ thuần cầu.
Thế bèo chúng cuộc khoảng bắn pháng tinh 앞에 ngay mình sọt tương,
ông Bero nhóm mạnh, Nguy cơ, Nguy chuyến bài của tỉ sảy ra sớm,
nếu tình trạm phong toả kéo dài, theo EF để là một phần của cuộc khủng hoàn năng lượng lượng nhất trong nhiều thật kỳ,
khi có khoảng hay biết phần trong lượng dòng xong tình trường,
đi qua, Vinh Mut, ông Bero can báo xan nếu liệu khi đốt và điện đều của tỉ tăng mạnh.
Tất động chự kép đến tăng chự kinh tỉ và lắm phát tần cầu,
ngay cả khi đạt được thuật hoàn hoàn bình,
bếc hoa phục sản luận và cứ sử hả tình nâng lượng có thể mất nhiều thắng.
Chong ngành hình không, một số hãng như Thế EF,
IZChat và Đưa Ta Alas,
cho biết chỉ phí như là tăng đất khi một số hãng phải có 3 truyền mạnh và điều trìng hoàn đập phay tháng.
E ai cũng cạnh báo nếu khu hằng kéo dài điểm của thân nằm nhiều dình thích tế có thể đối mặt với người cơ tăng trường trọng hoặc suy thái